and as soon as we were walking back from
the Starbucks I heard him keep a vehicle
I heard a loud scratching noise and as I
turned the corner there he was with keys
in his hand facing the vehicle
he was blocking my way saying I
scratched his car I didn't scratch his
car I'm a state senator I think he
recognized me I think he's one of the
gun nuts
he called out my name I never told him
my name that's definitely him that's his
face 100 all right and you're and you're
sure that you don't recognize him from
anywhere I've never seen him in my life
I didn't even know this guy existed saw
what appeared to be keys in the
gentleman's hand and you looked over and
saw a long scratch on his vehicle yeah
yeah it was just fresh it literally just
happened too scratches but that's a new
one
I kind of look like he tried to extend
it
this is the fresh one right here
right down here this one yeah no that's
uh
okay he apparently doesn't like my
stickers so that's all you need for me
[Applause]
if you're wishing to pursue charges for
the individual that's responsible
[Applause]
I was having an officer come down here
with the camera to take pictures
oh really yeah I'm sorry did you stick
around for a few minutes
how how long were you guys here for
before
you guys showed up you guys were here
for only about 10 minutes yeah and the
truck wasn't there when you guys you
guys pulled in first my son's in the
truck so I can't answer these questions
well do you know remember when the truck
was there one pulled up no it wasn't it
was some other vehicle and as soon as we
were walking back from the Starbucks I
heard him keep a vehicle but I heard a
loud scratching noise and as I turned
the corner there he was with keys in his
hand facing the vehicle
okay I have it there
[Applause]
huh
oh those taking pictures we'll get that
drink one yeah
here's the bag
I think that should be pretty much it
oh I need a signer right yeah yeah hold
on me this morning
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
how close were you when you heard it
oh no I was literally like right here
when I heard the peeing of the car
and right literally as I was kind of
corner he was walking out he was
literally right there next to the
scratch and like I said his skis are
like this in his hand and then he but he
was like just kept walking and saying
nothing I was like did you just keep my
car because I was like in a chocolate
serious and um
no and he just kept walking he even look
at us enough for himself
uh wait let me see Dad just put my yeah
okay I just want to make sure I put the
fourth down fourth William
all right so we just we just got to take
some pictures and stuff like that okay
yeah that's fine and then you guys can
go we just don't want to leave it like
that no I got you
I was on time today too I was on time
he said he walked off that way yeah he
walked off that way we try to I asked
him if he'd keep the car he said no and
he kept walking but I'd go for a fact he
did it there's no way he didn't do it
all right so he's out I'm shopping over
here somewhere okay
our brother was gonna go looking for him
now do you have any affiliation with the
owner of this truck okay
and you were in the truck at the time or
you were just walking no I was walking
back I was right here when I heard the
car getting key because I heard a lot of
scratching noise and like I told this
officer I've seen him like right where
that distracted right there as he was
leaving this area with keys in his hand
like this okay
and I asked him if he did it he said no
and he kept walking but there's no way
he didn't do it
[Music]
you know it's uh so it's your dad's
truck well it's under my husband's age
okay they don't like my stickers they
would keep telling me take them off I'm
like no yeah
hi
this is your truck and obviously the
Ridgeline wasn't here first no it wasn't
it was um a different vehicle at the
time when I parked I think it was a
white vehicle Okay so
and you were driving you you were
driving or you were driving no I was
driving I'm on the insurance
who's getting her a drink before I dance
like hurry up because we gotta go
do you know what he was wearing do you
remember what he was like he was wearing
like a suit jacket almost he was shorter
yeah
he was older gentleman
I think yeah I'm colorblind I think it
was either a green or anything
um
did you write all that down in the
statement you were given oh no I can't
make sure we get all that the full
description yeah you can just add it
right after that you say the description
of him is no whatever yeah
[Applause]
I don't know
yeah because I want to do all four sides
foreign
so
all right you get all the sides uh you
want all four hours I'll have to back
out so I can do all four sides straight
up I'll just move the scarf forward a
little bit
foreign
[Applause]
yeah you can tell by the little bit of
debris and a little splash on it make
sure
it looks like it's going that way too
see that little string right there yep
that's yeah that's that's that's from it
looks like it's going in that direction
okay
George
[Applause]
all right
okay all right uh last question I had
you simply you looked up the Republic
there you go he looks exactly like him
will you wait for him if I see his face
I'll know it yeah
um so you live nearby yeah
let me do you mind if I get everyone's
name all right
how you doing bud
I just need to step out the truck for me
all right sure do you mind shutting it
off
I'll explain you when you get out here
okay
you want to come right back here for me
five of them have one male to 10 for
right now all right listen
um I have to detain you for right now
all right I'm investigating a crime okay
okay all right if it's a maniac who
yelled at me in the car next to me uh
they weren't in the car next week
he was blocking my way saying I
scratched his car I didn't scratch his
car I'm a state senator I think he
recognized me
one of the gun nuts
he called out my name I never told him
my name all right he didn't say any of
that okay he definitely didn't recognize
you I know he he didn't say that yeah so
all right his car was keyed and it was
freshly keyed yeah all right and that's
what we're investigating right now okay
and seeing you know he pretty much heard
it and Sawyer yeah you got keys in your
hand as well that's because I just came
out of my car well that would make sense
but the way that he explained it yeah
seemed much uh a little bit more in
depth than that okay yeah all right you
know he can hear it like fresh it was
yeah if you can hear the scratching and
he approached you and asked you yeah
because he called out my name yeah he
didn't say he called out your name but
call out my name and I was worried that
he was one of the gun nuts Who stalked
me at the state house so I kept walking
well yeah I don't I don't I don't think
he was that he seemed a little young I
mean but that's not here yeah nor there
okay
um just for right now just hang out a
little bit all right I have a supervisor
uh coming out here okay
[Applause]
I was scared I like to walk all right
yeah
and I went over to Starbucks had a drink
calm down
and then I walked over the Whole Foods
together I needed to get when I came
back you you walked all the way to Whole
Foods yeah because I was afraid to come
back to my car and he was young
why didn't you call us it's a good
question I should have
[Applause]
five
you're gonna be off hey William how you
doing today as we spoke earlier
is there any way I can have you come
back to just ID the gentleman that you
said uh keep the car
yeah are you nearby
[Applause]
okay no problem
okay that's fine
[Music]
whoa what would you say he's wearing
all right I know it's it's it not it
it's all right if you're
colorblind that's it's not it's not
gonna you know I would definitely need
you to see him
yeah so you can't make it here in the
next a few minutes and then head right
back out
[Applause]
yep yep we are we're right in front of
the the Chipotle
[Applause]
okay
you were you were the one that
confronted him right
all right did you when when you
confronted him did you recognize him at
all do you know who he was before you
knew who he was you know what I mean
you didn't
at all you didn't you didn't recognize
him or anything never seen him
in your life before okay
all right no problem
okay
all right all right all right and you
guys are on the way
all right
okay
[Applause]
all right sir it's uh what's your last
name again sir Miller Miller Mr Miller
sir
um so this is going on right now okay we
have the victim that's gonna come down
yeah he's just gonna identify that he
who that you were the gentleman that he
spoke to about king's car okay there's
no charges yet we're still investigating
it okay we still have some you have
there are cameras yeah almost down each
and every row so okay obviously we have
to do our due diligence to make sure
yeah um we're just gonna detain you for
long until he comes down here
um he's coming from Province and you
should be here so Colonel windquist
knows that thank you
stockpiling Sky okay because I'm the
sponsor of assault yep
we actually they actually controlled my
house do you recognize this this
gentleman that I thought he called my
name okay so stickers on the back of my
car and I thought he said hey Miller
because I was concerned he was one of
these guys yep right
that stopped me I kept walking bro okay
oh that's absolutely fine
I have no problem with what you did like
after that also yeah um just so we can
you know again do our due diligence some
of these guys
I I trust me I completely understand
your concerns I said we obviously have a
job too we're just doing I do delegates
yeah
um just so we can like I said so we can
thoroughly investigate is it possible
just to see your keys so we can rule all
the possibilities
um
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll just hang out here for one second
sir
foreign
did you see the shirt that he's wearing
I know you're legally colorblind that's
why I was like I would have you come and
it looks like this yeah so I know you
can't see the colors but as long as you
can see the face and you can come out no
no no no I rather not have you guys come
together come together I know it's
definitely him I know he wasn't wearing
like the blue shirt or like a dark shirt
had a banana but you must I think he may
take it off right definitely have one on
but that's definitely him that's his
face 100 all right and you're and you're
sure that you don't recognize him from
anyone I've never seen him in my life I
didn't even know this guy exists
do you follow politics at all in the
state or anything like that you know I
don't even know any of the Senators to
be honest I only know the mayor you want
to know the mayor pretty much I know I'm
not a big yeah yeah so all right no he's
just I just want to make sure
um and are you sure that
scratch wasn't there before you oh I'm
100 sure that scratch is not there okay
I I know that that's fragile something
all right just you know just checking
and just trying to see maybe yeah maybe
it was there maybe it wasn't I
understand yeah definitely wasn't there
all right well that's all we need to
know all right for right now okay
we are gonna check out the cameras and
stuff because this place has really
really good cameras all right and then
after that if you know if we see fit
then we're gonna go from there all right
and then we'll notify you okay okay
absolutely all right
so
um we're gonna let you go at this point
it's still under investigation like I
said we'll wait until we do this footage
um we should have access to that
tomorrow okay and once we do at that
point our detectors are going to
probably conduct a further investigation
into it okay so right now potentially
you're facing um you're being
investigated for family so
um but like I said we're not taking
action now until we yeah
all right you want my phone number
um
I'll get my card out of control all
right sales on here your cells on there
as well all right okay all right perfect
[Music]
knows that I have this reaction tonight
because it's attached to me a couple of
times okay that's fine so we're not
taking any action right now
let them know that it was me and
absolutely that's that was my reaction
okay all right yeah sir you have a good
rest of your day okay appreciate your
helping the whole problem all right take
care
foreign
[Applause]
how are you good good you get a minute
yeah we came to talking about an
incident tonight that occurred in Garden
City yeah
um
so we have a complaint and wants to
pursue charges against you okay
um so we're gonna do our due diligence
and you know they spoke with you tonight
yeah we just go back to Garden City
we've got the uh video
of you going walking through Garden City
putting your shirt your coat over your
shoulder going to Whole Foods buying
your lettuce putting it in the bag I was
afraid to come back to the car because
he was he said hey Miller
yeah yeah
so we got here so you tell us how you
want to handle this your key this car
yeah and we can even make a big deal out
of this or a little deals okay whatever
you recommend well I want to know what
you recommend I mean I don't want to be
accused of covering up something for a
second neither do I so I think it's best
that we all be upfront with each other
and do the right thing here yeah I wanna
because you know it's uh he before he
even got to right
he was saying hey Miller what are you
going to do right yeah so I'm going to
be right up front with you here he saw
your sticker on your truck yeah and he
ran it and he saw your picture and he
said that's the guy just keep my car
yeah so he was upset and yeah I don't
know do you know the guy why would you
key his cat that's why that's I did
listen
he he was threatening there's a video
there's a video okay he was threatening
already
whatever you want me to do to make it
you know easiest for you guys and
everything
um so we're gonna probably go back and
get it we're gonna go back and get an
arrest warrant right but it's it's you
rather than do that you can either come
to the police station we can charge you
there yeah um this guy wants to pursue
charges he's upset that is his cause
um well Keith I I we were going to do a
search warrant take your keys and stuff
like that but I think you're gonna
cooperate yeah
um do you why did you keep do you know
like the expression he was already he
was already threatening okay yeah all
right so what are these so you want to
give a statement did what did he threat
how did he threaten you because we can't
hear what said we can't see before I as
soon as I open my door yep he started
saying hey Miller what are you gonna do
right yeah you know he already started
on me as soon as I opened my door right
and then which which guy was that
because it was two guys yeah I don't
know which guy all right yeah so he he
did he bang your car with the door or
something before that or like why would
as soon as I came out of the car you
just got mad and keyed his car because
he was already screaming at night all
right yeah
all right yeah why don't we do this if
you you want to just come to the We're
not gonna go doing a restaurant for you
and and roll it out that way why don't
you we just
and it would probably be it's up to you
you could write a statement saying he
threatened you know whatever the case
was yeah and then um you know I keyed it
out of out of what I don't know anger I
don't know what your issue was
yeah did he threaten you at all or I
thought he was threatening me based on
you know just my history with guys over
there yeah
what do you means like guys like that
was he the I thought he was one of the
gun nuts that you know stalked me before
so okay yeah do you recognize him or no
I just I thought he was okay yeah all
right
all right why don't we do this here
because it's a misdemeanor yeah
um I think the guy just wants his
restitution to get his car fixed I mean
it's key pretty bad I gotta be honest
with you yeah what did you do with your
keys or
well I was I took my keys out when he
started yelling at me yeah
all right yeah
because that's I mean you gotta there's
there's a lot I mean you could see
you're between the cars and yeah I mean
it's obvious that
it I I don't know I mean it's you it's
we'll we'll deal with it
so right but they're gonna what's the
reason to key the car though that's the
question because he was daring me two
faces okay all right all right so why
don't we do this yet you want to just
throw a pair of shoes on come to the
station we'll yeah
all right bang it out real quick and get
you out of there it's up to yeah it's a
misdemeanor like I said it's a cap does
he need cap does he need money
um you're gonna do JP for him or yes
yes okay bring 50 bucks and whoever the
adjusted the piece is on duty will come
in just get you out of there okay all
right Santa have a good night yep all
right I'm gonna come in here which is so
you know I mean like I I gotta follow
you in so you can grab a pair of shoes
unless there's a pair of shoes like
right here all right sir yeah all right
I gotta come in there with you
arrested
[Applause]
what
I don't know there we go
oh man good evening hi
he'll be back shortly okay he's gonna
get JP now do you have uh Senator do you
have a 50 bucks handy yeah yeah all
right
getting arrested for what
I'll let you
know
all right so I'm going down
he says I keyed his car so I'm going
down heed his car what's that mean
scrape his card
who said that the guy who I parked next
to no
somebody parked next to said you keep
your car you had to go down to the
station
yeah oh geez
the center I believe it's gonna be cash
I think the I think the Justice of the
piece exceptional except cash only oh I
got some I got some let me just make
sure I got enough
yeah yeah
you got 100 bucks right there yeah they
you want me to yeah just bring all of it
just in case but I'm it's 50 bucks
they usually carry change as well yeah
they they usually okay I got enough
all right anything extra you want to
leave behind just I want to get my feet
the left yeah Keys the less you bring
the better but yeah Keys is a good move
yeah
all right so come on we're ready
just
just right here it's fine sir I just I
just I'm gonna shut this door for you
and your wife okay and uh we'll step
right out little let him if he wants to
give a statement all right threatened
him or whatever when he got this let him
give that to add that for the report
okay okay there you go sir I'm just
gonna put these on you what yeah I'm not
gonna do anything else I'm driving yeah
you want me to drive you're driving I'll
meet us at the station okay all right do
you have your keys yeah I did yeah
that's fine if he wants to do that right
actually five